dear fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr Carol Jonah today we are
going to give a really hard time to a
robot look at this and this you see
Google's robots are getting smarter and
smarter every year for instance we
talked about this robot assistant where
we can say please help me I have spilled
the Coke and then it creates a cunning
plan it tries to throw out the Coke can
well almost then it brings us a sponge
and if we have been reading research
papers all day and we feel a little
tired if we tell it it can bring us a
water bottle hand it to us and can even
bring us an apple a different robot of
theirs has learned to drive itself also
understands English and can thus take
instructions from us and find its way
around and these instructions can be
really nasty like this one however there
is one thing that neither of these
previous robots can do but this new one
can let's see what it is first let's ask
for a soda again and once again it comes
up with a canning plan go to the Coke
can pick it up and
Checkmate little robot now comes the
coolest part it realizes that it has
failed and now change of plans it says
the following there is no Coke but there
is an orange soda is that okay with us
no no we are going to be a little picky
here and say no and ask for a lime soda
instead the robot probably thinks oh
goodness a change of plans again let's
look for that lime soda and it is of
course really far away to give it a hard
time so let's see what it does
wow look at that it found it in the
other end of the room recognized that
this is indeed the soda picks it up and
we are done so cool the amenities at the
Google headquarters are truly Next Level
I love it this was super fun so you know
what let's try another task let's ask it
to put the Coke can into the top drawer
will it succeed well look at that the
human operator cannot wait to mess with
this little robot and aha sure enough
that drawer is not opening so is this a
problem well the robot recognized that
this was not successful but now the
environment has changed the pesky human
is gone so it tries again and this time
the drawer opens in goes the Coke can it
holds the drawer with both fingers
and now I just need a gentle little push
and
Bravo good job we tried to confuse this
robot by messing up the environment and
it did really well but now get this what
if we mess with its brain instead how
well check this out let's ask it to
throw away the snack on the counter it
asks which one and to which our answer
is of course not the Apple no no let's
mess with it a little more our answer is
that we changed our mind so please throw
away something on the table instead okay
now as it approaches the table let's try
to mess with it again you know what
never mind just finish the previous task
instead and it finally goes there and
grabs the Apple we tried really hard but
we could not mess with this guy so cool
so a new robot that understands English
can move around make a plan and most
importantly it can come up with a plan B
when plan a fares wow a little personal
assistant the piece of progress in AI
research is nothing short of amazing
what a time to be alive so what would
you use this for let me know in the
comments below if you're looking for
inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda now
offers the best prices in the world for
GPU Cloud compute no commitment or
negotiation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with Lambda GPU Cloud you
can get on-demand a100 instances for
1.10 per hour versus 4.10 per hour with
AWS that's 73 savings did I mentioned
they also offer persistent storage so
join researchers at organizations like
apple MIT and Caltech in using Lambda
Cloud instances workstations or servers
make sure to go to lambdalabs.com papers
to sign up for one of their amazing GPU
instances today thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time